talât validé quelle question allez vous
donc posé aujourd'hui au gouvernement je
simplement demandé au gouvernement
quelle est sa position sur cette
jurisprudence qui est importante qui va
maintenant être une référence pour tous
les départements français le
gouvernement s'ils le souhaitent de
voter une loi qui va contre le sens de
cette jurisprudence
ou au contraire il peut la conforter
cette décision bien entendu autorise le
recours au bénévolat conditionnée au
versement du rsa mais il faut aussi
l'encadré on ne peut pas laisser les
conseils départementaux dans un vide
juridique et fixer des règles précises
au niveau législatif et je vais
interroger le gouvernement pour savoir
s'ils sont prêts à accepter une
proposition doit qui peut émaner de
l'opposition il serait prêt à en
discuter à l'accepter est ce que vous
comprenez que cette mesure elle fasse
polémique elle peut laisser penser et
bien que les bénéficiaires du rsa ne
cherche pas suffisamment ne font pas
assez de choses pour te retrouver un
emploi ça a beaucoup évolué et lorsque
je l'avais lancé en février 2016
il y avait des centaines d'articles qui
s'y opposaient aujourd'hui il faut
chercher des articles sur pose l'opinion
publique et même les associations ont
considérablement évolué y compris le
président a public s'est déclaré plutôt
favorable lors du dernier du congrès de
l'association des départements de france
je vous remercie vous allez donc posé
cette question verra la réponse du
gouvernement
merci à